[Musique]
j'ai eu l'occasion de dial et il ya deux
ans en tant que qu'accompagnatrice pour
des clients deux années de suite
d'ailleurs ça m'a donné envie de
répondre présente cette année pour faire
cette aventure humaine au sein
d'entreprises qui reste quand même
privilégié pour nous en tant que salarié
d'habitude je travaille dans dans les
bureaux fin donc à ça va me permettre de
faire un petit peu la route avec avec
l'entreprise l'accompagner durant ses
différentes étapes
c'est un challenge personnel c'est voilà
échanger avec les gens avec des
collègues que je voit pas habituellement
parce qu'ils sont sur d'autres sites
donc voilà c'est une expérience que j'ai
envie de vivre voir l'envers du décor
jonathan de ressortir avec avec autant
de joie que j'en ai avant de partir de
pouvoir participer de pouvoir faire
toutes ces étapes à bord d'un véhicule
de l'entreprise de mettre en avant sa
société chacun de partager avec avec des
personnes extérieures ou en interne avec
l'entreprise